this video is sponsored by longevity
technology our results reveal that the
microbiome may be a suitable therapeutic
target to promote healthy aging
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we are
going to discuss the gut microbiome and
its connection to brain aging so by the
end of this video you will understand
what some scientists have done to
improve the brain health of some old
mice and what this all has to do with
the gut microbiome so firstly what
actually is the gut microbiome well it
refers to the collection of all the
different microorganisms such as
bacteria fungi and viruses that inhabit
our gut
and our microbiomes aren't just
passengers hanging around in our body
they actually perform a variety of
different functions such as helping with
the digestion of foods but beyond that
the gut microbiome has also been linked
with mediating various processes
including shaping our immune response
and so unsurprisingly dysbiosis or
fargott microbiome has also been linked
to several different diseases
in particular it's been associated with
obesity and type 2 diabetes
so it may not come as surprised as well
that the microbiome has been shown to
change with age and there's actually
been a study that's shown that you can
use the microbiome to be able to predict
someone's biological age which is pretty
cool and so because of these connections
a lot of research has been investigated
in understanding the gut microbiome and
some more recent markers shown that it's
also involved in metabolism and brain
health
and so given that the gut microbiome
undergoes many changes during aging if
there was a way to counteract these
changes would it also have improvements
on these different diseases well this is
kind of a big question and to kind of
address it you need to study it in modal
organisms first and focus on more
specific outcomes and so this brings us
on to this recent nature aging
publication i wanted to see if the
microbiota from young mice could help to
rejuvenate
signs of aging in the brain of odomites
and so the lovely way that you can test
this is through a process known as fecal
microbiota transplantation and so i was
going to explain exactly how this
procedure works but having read the
methods section of this paper i feel
like we'll save that for another day and
simply look at this delightful figure
that shows broadly what happens
so anyway now that we understand the
procedure what they did was they took
the fecal microbiota from young mice
that were aged around three to four
months and transplanted this into aged
mites that were around 19 to 20 months
and as a control they also gave the aged
mice fecal microbiota from older mice
and they also gave young mice microbiota
from young mice
and these transplantations were
continued throughout the rest of the
study and as you can see here they did a
variety of different measurements and
these range from assessing brain
immunity to looking at more complex
behavioral functions but firstly did the
microbiota composition even change
well to some extent yes and the case
pointed out by the authors where changes
seen in the enterococcus general
whereby you can see that the age mice
that were given the young microbiator to
a greater abundance more closely
resembling what's seen in the younger
mice
and that's interesting given the fact
that some enterococcus species are
already being used as probiotics to
improve animal health
but did any of these changes actually
reflect an improvement in immune
function or brain health
well to assess brain health they looked
at the hippocampus of these mice which
is a small region of the brain involved
in learning and memory
and given that the microbiome generates
a load of different chemicals that they
secrete into the body they first assess
the hippocampal metabolome and so this
figure shows how there's many different
changes in the metabolites in age mice
that were given the young fecal
microbiota compared to given old
microbiota
and 35 of the metabolites that were
altered in aging were restored towards
pre-age levels by the introduction of
this young fecal microbiota and of these
metabolites that already have no new
connections between neurotransmission
and aging the authors identified retinol
or vitamin a
gamma-aminobutyric acid known as gaba
and
glycolyranamate and also arginine and
other metabolites were enriched in
pathways involved in amino acid
metabolism and trna biosynthesis
and so this is all interesting because a
lot of these metabolites are linked with
proper brain function for example a
previous study has shown that vitamin a
supplementation prevents age-related
spatial memory deficits and arginine has
been linked to neurodegeneration
and so they saw some restorative changes
in the metabolism in the hippocampus of
these aged mice given young fecal
microbiota but that doesn't have any
functional consequences
well as i mentioned in the study they
also assessed a variety of different
behavioral tests with the mice given
young fecal microbiota and one of these
tests that they did included the morris
water maze which is a way of determining
hippocampal dependent long-term spatial
memory and so typically hmi show
impairments in the ability to perform
this task but this was somewhat improved
in the hmis that had received the young
microbiota now one reason why this might
have happened is because there's
improved neurogenesis the development of
new neuronal cells however there was no
evidence to support increased
neurogenesis in these mice
and so it's more likely that these
changes in metabolites are having the
influence seen in their behavior however
this requires further investigation
and so the last aspect they looked at
was whether or not the gut microbiota
from the young mice could have any
influence over host immunity in the old
mice and so the immune cells of the
brain are the microglial and typically
during aging it's observed that there's
enlargement of these microglia which
reflects increased activation of the
microglia that's also been associated
with neurodegenerative conditions
and so the old mice that were given the
young fecal microbiota showed a
reduction in the size of their microglia
suggesting that the fecal microbiota
transfer
could be modulating hippocampal immunity
however the transfer didn't reverse
age-associated reductions in interferon
gamma or interleukin-5 suggesting that
the transfer may be selectively
modulating peripheral immunity and so
this work raises a number of questions
the major one being what is the
mechanism behind these differences
whilst they saw changes in the
metabolism in the hippocampus is that
because the microbiome were producing
these compounds or were they synthesized
within the brain
and could those metabolites alone or in
combination refers to morphological and
functional alterations in the aging
hippocampus as opposed to actually
having the fecal microbiome transfer
particularly because well
there may be some reasons why people
would object to such a treatment but
also due to the fact that in this paper
the mice had to have continued treatment
throughout the whole time
and so that raises the second question
as well how long do these effects last
is it like a one-time thing and then
they'll be fine for the remainder or how
frequent would these treatments need to
be for the mice to show these continued
improvements
another interesting point to raise is
the fact that the fecal microbiome
transfers only take the microbiome from
well the fecal material and that
actually doesn't necessarily reflect the
whole gut microbiome profile of the
young mice and so it'd be interesting to
know if actually having a better
representation of the young gut
microbiome
in the older mice would maybe show more
benefits
and speaking more just on the method
itself it's worth pointing out that
heterologous fecal microbiome transfer
is a highly successful and
cost-effective therapy for the treatment
of recurrent see difficile infection
however another concern with doing these
treatments is the long-term safety of
the procedure and potential exposure to
life-threatening infectious diseases an
alternative is autologous fmt therapy so
that would be banking your own stool
samples when healthy to later rebalance
your gut microbiome
which um i'll let you have your own
opinions on that
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video longevity
technology for which i'm very grateful
longevity technology delivers high
quality daily news and insights on
research investments and technologies
that extend health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description
so i hope you've learnt something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening